[Music]
thank you so much for coming to hear me
talk about the mathematics of thought
something that is that interests me very
much in my research and the basic
question I'm asking myself is how does
mathematics shape our conceptualization
of reality now you might think well in
some sense there is really trivial
answer to this and this is because
mathematical methods are actually
everywhere especially in the empirical
sciences for example in physics physical
theories couldn't be formulated without
the use of mathematics but also in other
Natural Sciences for example in biology
we use mathematical models in order to
study the behavior of certain well
patterns of organisms and in sociology
we use mathematics in order to study
social networks so in that sense
mathematical methods are everywhere in
the empirical science isn't because the
empirical science has shaped the way we
see reality well naturally mathematics
has a part in that as well and this is
because it is an indispensable
scientific tool but this is not what I'm
interested in in my research I'm more
interested in mathematics as a
philosophical paradigm and in order to
give you an idea of what that means I'm
going to introduce five examples from
the history of philosophy to you so the
first one of course is Plato who
considered mathematical knowledge the
highest form of knowledge and in fact
tradition has it that he had the
sentence
let no one ignorant of geometry enter
here engraved on top of the entrance to
his Academy so he thought that
proficiency in mathematics was a
prerequisite for the acquisition of any
further knowledge whatsoever Galileo had
a slightly different view he believed
that language that mathematics was the
language of the book of nature and he
thought that it was the scientists task
to become proficient in that language
and thereby study the fundamental
structures of reality although kunt had
a very special place in his philosophy
for mathematics
so he thought that mathematics is a
prime example for a particular class of
human judgments judgments he called
judgments synthetic a priori and those
are judgments that are on the one hand
we formed without consulting our
experience beforehand but on the other
hand they're not empty judgments like
analytical judgments but we actually get
to learn something new in those
judgments and he thought that
mathematics was the prime example of
synthetic a priori judgments and that we
could learn how these judgments work in
different contexts also Nietzsche
believed that mathematics actually is a
paradigm of refinement and rigor and he
thought that all other sciences should
strive to be as much as possible like
mathematics in that respect and then
finally and perhaps most bizarrely and
so this is why it's my favorite example
gira Kant or probably one of the most
important mathematicians of all time at
least I think so who proved that there
are infinities of different sizes so
there is the infinity of the natural
numbers and he proved with an actually
actually with a very straightforward and
simple proof that the set of real
numbers is larger than the set of
natural numbers even though both are
infinitely large and so he and he called
these number these sizes of infinities
transfinite numbers and the idea of an
absolute infinite he thought was a
manifestation of God
so Cantor actually found something
divine in mathematics in order to give
you a slightly better picture of what
fascinates me about this I'm going to
say a few words about the relationship
between mathematics and the empirical
sciences and how this relationship has
evolved over time and again I'm going to
start an ancient Greece and so for the
ancient Greeks I'm talking now about
Plato the pythagoreans and most most of
all of course
Euclid mathematics was above all it was
where the it was the only
source of true knowledge of absolutely
certain knowledge whereas our beliefs
about the empirical world were
considered to be mere opinions why
because the empirical world is
constantly in flux it's constantly
changing and so he thought well it's
impossible to have certain knowledge
about something that is ever-changing so
what we see here is that mathematics is
the sort of the kind of knowledge above
all and the empirical world is something
we can have opinions about but not
really know anything about a very very
distinct separation between the two
realms now this picture changed
dramatically during the times of the
Scientific Revolution many centuries
later when empirical scientists really
started to blossom and the exploration
of the empirical world started to become
more and more systematic so now we've
arrived at a picture where mathematics
as I mentioned earlier was considered
the language of the book of nature and
the task of the scientist was considered
to well learn the language and figure
out the the basic laws according to
which the universe is structured and
these laws were thought to be
mathematical laws so by putting
mathematical laws in relation to our
observations we the scientists was
supposed to understand the fundamental
truths of reality this picture changed
again in the 19th century the time we
now call empiricism so during that time
the fortunes of mathematics were
completely reversed again the
empiricists for example of the vienna
circle believed that mathematics
actually didn't have any content of its
own it's a mere tool a very useful tool
for the empirical sciences but a mere
tool nevertheless and the only source of
certain well grounded knowledge was
considered to be the empirical sciences
so as you have noticed we have sort of
this movement where mathematics started
off as being this highest form of
knowledge then it's sort of
merged with the empirical sciences and
then the empirical sciences became our
paradigm of well-grounded knowledge and
mathematics was considered to be a mere
tool for for the sciences another way of
saying saying this is that mathematics
started off as something that could be
called the language of God actually the
ancient Greeks believed that the reason
that we find sort of imperfect
geometrical figures in the empirical
world is because the gods gave geometry
to the world sort of instill geometrical
language in nature in order to make us
understand that this nature is an
intelligible an environment that isn't
al intelligible to us during scientific
revolution then mathematics became the
language of nature and during empiricist
times it had become or taken a fall down
to the level of a mere language of men
and what we see here what I want to
point out to you is continuous
dissociation of mathematics from the
physical world and the crossover point
that I mentioned earlier coincides
roughly with the rise of pure
mathematics so in the 19th century
mathematical concepts that had little or
even no physical meaning whatsoever
started to be introduced by
mathematicians as legitimate objects of
mathematical study for example in
dimensional spaces transfinite numbers
non-euclidean geometries complex numbers
all these mathematical objects that
didn't have any clear physical meaning
anymore and so mathematics in that sense
moved beyond concepts that were
suggested directly by our experience of
physical reality and so at the beginning
of the 20th century the situation was as
follows I'm going to quote Morris Klein
here perhaps the most important or the
most well-known historian of mathematics
he writes very nicely the circle within
which mathematical studies appear to be
enclosed at the beginning
the 19th century that circle being
applicability to the physical world was
broken at all points and mathematics
exploded into a hundred branches each
one built on its own system of axioms so
that's actually a very vivid picture of
what happened to mathematics exploded
into these all these different subfields
and people working in these different
subfields wouldn't necessarily talk much
to people working in other mathematical
subfields and of course you're probably
expecting this there was yet another
paradigm change in the in the first half
of the 20th century set theory one
branch of mathematics all of a sudden
acquired a lot of importance and this
was because a group of French
mathematicians they were working under
the under the sort of pen name Bourbaki
group started to prove that set theory
is actually a foundation for all of
mathematics they showed that we can
express all mathematical theorems in the
language of set theory which of course
made visible the interconnections
between all these different branches of
mathematics it also helped precise if I
certain concepts that had hitherto been
slightly vague or unclear it made
visible the fundamental assumptions that
were being made in all the different
branches of mathematics and most
importantly it provided a unified
framework a unified language in which
all the different branches of
mathematics could be interpreted for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute's of
Arts and ideas at AI
TV
you